wah
our mariachi florida Toloache is
different than most varieties were
formed in New York City we're all women
most people think of mariachis being
from Mexico as being men as being macho
and you know we're pretty much opposite
of all those things I started my musical
career playing with a local all-male
mariachi in Brooklyn for me was really
hard to communicate with other male
mariachis because of the machismo
that's very vivid and the culture and in
the jammer of mariachi that's kind of
why I I wanted to start my own group and
that lit for me to do a all-female group
because I didn't want to deal with men
and it's not so much that people say
you're not a mariachi but it's the fact
that they think that we cannot play my
deity because we're women and we're
wearing pens and we have curly hair and
we don't look Mexican or we don't have
this look that they're expecting as a
women mariachi we're technically
supposed to be wearing skirts and didn't
work for us
that's one of the most passionate music
that I've ever heard it's just beautiful
it's very hard felt and I think that's
what makes money at you're so special
my dream to be able to perform and
connect with people through music I
don't think I could ask for more you
know that's what keeps us going
thank you so much good answer man thank
you so much everybody
we love you let me down